this rather futuristic looking device
has transformed Annie Lovett's Life
Annie suffers from depression and at its
worst she was bed bound she tried
medication but didn't feel it was
working and struggled to sleep as a side
effect trying this headset changed
everything it was really unwell really
unhappy
um and yeah this is just something it's
kind of it felt like a last resort
and it was like if this doesn't work I
don't know what will and I was really
lucky that it did
for Annie to notice a real difference it
was like that it was like a switch foot
and it was just so much better like one
morning I just remember waking up and
noticing that I just felt better like I
just felt more able to get out of bed
and get on with life the device is made
by a Swedish company called flow
neuroscience and it's not cheap 400
pounds full price it works by using
electric pulses to increase brain
activity and reduce the symptoms of
depression
in fact in Trials almost 90 percent of
patients reported being in remission
after just six weeks now it's being
tested out within the NHS if you look at
the overall benefits it can give to our
patients by reducing the number of
attendances in the GP surgeries in the
attendance with the healthcare
professionals I think it will give a
benefit overall cost will not matter if
it's giving so much benefits to our
patients I he's been using her headset
headset fought with it I think sort of
when I've had a relapse and I started to
feel unwell again I'll start using it
again now she uses it twice a week
consistently wearing it in 30-minute
sessions while she watches TV and
crochets but there are concerns about
how the treatment works long term the
main question that has risen so far with
regards to this device is that you know
it works as long as you're using it but
when you stop it what happens I mean is
the person cured of depression does the
person relapse Oscar
Annie has also been having therapy a way
to treat the causes of depression too
often those desperately in need of
counseling face huge waiting lists could
this device become as widely used as
medication to treat the symptoms of what
can be an utterly debilitating mental
illness Becky Cottrell Sky News